hey everyone I'm Katie and I'm here at
EP and LP where I have challenged two of
LA's most creative chefs to make a dish
featuring a food item that is absolutely
positively hated by a self-proclaimed
picky eater and they're gonna try to get
them to love it will it be seafood will
it be brussel sprouts will it be cottage
cheese let's go meet our picky eater
find out what they hate so we can feed
it to them
hi I am destiny and I'm a picky eater
hello I'm very picky I'm trying to work
on it but it's just really hard some
foods just taste nasty the texture is
horrible and I just can't do it my top
10 most hated foods are mushrooms
cottage cheese avocado sweet potato blue
cheese zucchini squash tomatoes onions
and peas the thought of eating foods
that I hate I don't know why it just
makes me nervous like I'm not gonna die
but it's just like but it's just a
really nerve-wracking feeling like I'm
so nervous all right guys Justin a
really picky eater we've got her in the
back and what she doesn't know is that
she's gonna be trying two dishes with
everyone's favorite edible fungus
mushrooms so let's go meet her chefs and
find out what they're cooking up hi guys
I'm Ellen Bennett and I used to cook
professionally but now I run Headley and
Bennett so today I'm gonna make destiny
mushroom lasagna and I'm gonna use four
mushrooms to do it I think she's not
even know what hit her and I'm really
excited to see if she likes them I'm
pretty sure I can turn this picky eater
into a believer let's get to work I'm
going to start with getting some oil
into my pan I'm going to start with
celery parsnips and shallots
I love shallots they don't punch you in
the face like an onion and you know they
had a baby with a garlic what could go
wrong this is starting to get some color
it's nice I'm gonna go ahead and add the
mushrooms now I'm gonna throw this in
now I took trumpet mushrooms shiitake
mushrooms cremini mushrooms and
portobello mushrooms so poor mushroom
I'm gonna move on to my bechamel
I'm going to throw our garlic in I cut a
shallot very quickly because I wanted to
add that in I'm just gonna let that
shallot go a little bit here oh man that
smells cool like velvety butter magic
now I'm gonna get cornstarch
this is cornstarch and I'm adding water
to it I'm gonna make a quick little
paste I can add it here and just whisk
it in pretty immediately seconds you can
add the milk you want to have it room
temp which I have it at so this becomes
a really beautiful creamy substance that
like binds everything together it's like
the glue I'm gonna add pepper to it salt
I'm gonna salt these guys too I'm gonna
add some garlic to the mushroom this is
starting to brown this is almost ready
here oh so good okay i melted a little
bit more butter in there and now I am
going to deglaze and you want to scrape
those suckers in you cannot leave a man
behind you got to get all of them and
then I'm gonna throw the lasagna and the
noodles that I already have in my hand
I'm throwing them in over here just
super quick so they're like like a
noodle but not like a super noodle like
a medium noodle you know new to leave if
you will and we're almost ready now it's
like the final countdown this is looking
so beautiful magical man
that one more layer I've done this three
times now it's gonna let it go I'm not
gonna add more liquid this guy ready to
go and add a little parmesan to this and
if you have parmesan Ryan you can add
that in here too so I've got my xinhua
I'm really just gonna drain this to get
all the magical bits out of there this
is great our mushrooms are great I'm
kind of like we did with the wine I'm
getting all of that beautiful layer on
the bottom you could only smell this
we're ready to build let's do this
more importantly hold on okay we go so
we did three layers of pasta
two-and-a-half layers of parmesan we
threw the mushroom bolognaise inside in
between each layer then we're gonna do
sage because come on you got to get that
Instagram moment now we're gonna throw
it in the oven I'm gonna cover it with
aluminum foil at 30 minutes I'm going to
take it off Royall it and bam we're done
I'm gonna go ahead and plate this and
I'm so excited to see what destiny
thinks you can add a couple other layers
of things I hit it with a little bit
more olive oil a little bit of fresh
parmigiano-reggiano on here and a touch
of pepper a little bit of parsley and
it's ready to go let's do this hi my
name is Samuel Braganza and I'm the new
head chef at a P&L tea restaurant in
West Hollywood
today I'm making destiny something
that's currently on our menu a mushroom
Dondon noodle I'm actually using a
oyster and shiitake mushroom very Asian
mushrooms to use and I'm a cork for
aiding them in small pieces in a sauce
that's on top of the noodle I totally
think I could make destiny a mushroom
lover let's get cooking so the start of
this downtown noodle dish is actually
really in the chili garlic paste that we
make beforehand we cut down a lot of
shallots a lot of garlic and some oil
and then we put some Szechuan
Szechuan peppercorn in the case we
soaked some dried California puya and
Thai chilies
and then you put some soybean paste
that's fermented soybeans vanessi you
use a soy sauce to flavor it and some
sugar and this right here is our actual
final sauce that we cook the mushrooms
in as a base of our dish these are fresh
meat noodles it actually only takes
three minutes to cook it's a very fast
pickup because we're working with a
watch station right here watch stations
actually my favorite station I think
it's the most fun so you want to heat up
the wok first before adding the oil if
you put the oil and heat up the wok got
a burnt taste inside of the smoked
seafood flavor the oil a little bit you
get a little garlic and celery flavor
pinky that gets brown really quickly
this is a mix of pet shiitake and oyster
mushroom you want a stir fry it in the
watch and get that brown flavor you want
to keep the wok moving because there's a
difference between char and burnt just
on a high key you keep it moving and get
that flavor you get that even top if
that fire firework going and we'll add
our chili paste that we've made already
that's right here then I showed you the
ingredients for get him out because
that's like where all the flavor is it's
already cooked out but you want to
caramelize it a bit those mushrooms are
sponges they're gonna absorb all the
chilies and the garlic now we already
cooked down in prep time and a little
more seasoning add some soy sauce a
little bit of sweet place for sweetness
I add some veg stock
start with juicing it down so you see it
starting to thicken and thicken so it
tastes like savory the vegetable stock
what she made is actually infused with a
lot of ginger and some lemongrass in
there this our house veg stock to finish
I add toasted ground sesame seeds and it
adds like a voluptuousness thickness all
right the noodles are cooked they have a
bit of chew on them you take the noodles
out of our boiler and into our Bowl
reduce it down stick nice we'll pour it
all over our noodles next this is a
black vinegar and then I'll put some
chili flake to give it some a little
more spice in a little more color this
is a ginger scallion relish that we make
in-house we have some scallion jewels a
little cilantro
I like this with a lot of cucumber cuz
it really it's like such a warm savory
dish you need this much herb this much
cucumber it's much ginger and just such
a bit vinegar to really balance it out
here we go mushroom don don noodles
all right destiny hello how are you
feeling I'm nervous I'm not gonna lie
like my stomach is literally like
turning have we ever steered you wrong
it tastes to you before I mean this is
the absolute worst BuzzFeed video I have
ever been Oh's this is like okay we
absolutely okay we did that was the Pats
those in the past
look this is before we're moving forward
like a good relationship I really think
that these two dishes could change your
mind I'm open are you open
it's so okay well I'm very excited I
guess you should just get the dishes out
here and we'll give it a try let's do it
oh boy oh boy oh boy okay these look
delicious yeah they do can you tell what
we're gonna feed you honestly they smell
delicious like I cannot tell what's in
them it is very hard I think that's like
great right which one are you gonna try
first so sure this my first okay all
right Oh for it I'm like nervous and
excited for you you're nervous
that is so good
that is so good is the quote oh my god
and you're eating something you hate
oh you don't know what of it I don't
know what it is but I'm scared
do you have any guesses now mmm guessing
mushroom are you tasty mushroom I'm not
tasting mushroom I don't like a little
spice on it yeah the noodles oh it's
just delicious
great so success and then you still have
a second one to try I'm so excited ready
yes let's do it let's get that in there
swap a roux swap roux that was my
biggest fear the mushroom yeah it's not
scary at all not at all no all right
we'll do it get in the hair do you keep
smelling it okay mmm so good it's not is
it so good
yep try it you have okay this okay here
we go girl
Wow that is delicious
I should eat this every day so then you
have a really hard decision to me I do
it seems like you vote you love both of
these a lot I think you have to decide
on guava they're gonna break some ships
heart oh no just a meeting like today
will be okay okay between the two yeah
I'm gonna have to go
oh my gosh delicious book we're so tight
I would say that in my eyes we are all
still winners here because we helped to
make mushrooms part of her life in the
future well chefs label thank you so
much for making this for me it was so
good thank you so much and if you ever
want to try it again it's actually on
the menu right now as a vegan down down
[ __ ] come back and visit me and try the
rest of the dishes that EP NLT Thank You
Sabo you are literally changing lives so
leave in the comments if there are foods
you think you hate and maybe we can make
believers out of you I am Katie and
thank you guys for watching let's eat
good about them no kidding oh yes
[Music]
you